do the best you can with what you've got
you may be limited in how many resources
you have but as an entrepreneur you have
to be unlimited in your resourcefulness
hi I'm Evan Carmichael your friend and
all things entrepreneurship and today I
want to tell you the story about Julian
or Clark the founder of baby einstein
painter Clark was a stay-at-home mom she
was tired of not having enough education
materials for her new baby daughter and
so she thought I'm gonna create my own
video series to help her but she didn't
have the money to do it so here's what
she didn't do she didn't go to the banks
she didn't go to the venture capitalist
she didn't go to the angel investors
trying to raise money for this but she
also didn't give up she didn't say I
don't have the money to do this so I'm
not gonna try here's what you did do she
bought some film equipment on her friend
she started filming herself and put
these handmade puppets on her hand and
she was a star and her and her husband
edited the videos on their home computer
and the first baby einstein videos were
created she would go on to build a
company with 20 million dollars in sales
before she got acquired by disney she
got her big payday because she didn't
give up she didn't let lack of money
hold her back she did the best she could
with what she had that's your lesson for
today good luck
you
you